you've had people that we sadly missed
along the way
you had the great prince on your show uh
i have a good i have a
great prince story prince one time
prince is coming on the show and his
his manager calls and says hey prince uh
would love a ping pong
to play ping pong on the show i go okay
uh we'll get a ping-pong table no
problem so he comes on the show we have
the
never brings up ping pong doesn't talk
about it never brings it up
doesn't even mention it i go whatever he
crack he crushes he's awesome
he's great that's the end of that and a
month later i'm at dinner and i get a
text
and i go it says from hi this is
prince's manager
prince wants to meet you right now at a
club
called spin in new york city uh it's a
nightclub it's a ping pong nightclub
wow what so i go to my friend go i gotta
go
prince wants to play me in ping pong
he wants to meet me on 23rd and i go i
gotta go so i get in the cab i go to
this place
i go down the steps uh downstairs and i
go
hi i'm i'm here to see um in the girls
print yeah he's in this
the private room back there behind the
curtain i go okay
so i go in i open this curtain and who's
standing there
a prince in a double-breasted uh
like crushed velvet suit and uh he's
holding a ping-pong
paddle and he goes you ready for
and i go uh yeah this is so surreal
there's no one else in the room
just me and prince so i go uh oh i guess
i go he goes do you want to warm up i go
it doesn't matter i mean i'm not even
good at ping pong but i'll play with you
and he's like
uh oh here we go and so he's he's he
serves and he gets the point and he goes
one's it i go oh we're going to talk
smack here we go let's go prince let's
go let's play now now i'm like ready
to play prince i'm like let's go so i'm
trying to play back i'm not good at ping
pong
long story long uh he's crushing so he's
like
game point i go okay and he hits the
serve
and it's like and it's one of those
perfect ping-pong the things are
spinning
flames are coming off the ball and it's
coming and it hits
that one corner of the ping-pong table
you know that's impossible to hit back
and he hits the thing and go and he goes
i go oh my gosh you won you won you know
let me go so
i look over to pick up the ball i come
back
and uh he's gone he's gone
and i don't know that well so i'm like
prince great and then is he hiding under
the table so like print
prince it was so weird i go
and i walk out and there's like a velvet
rope and it was kind of swinging back
and forth a little bit it sounds like
batman was there or something
and then questlove who's our band leader
here you know from the roots
heard about this ping-pong game and took
a cab over it and he actually saw
prince's limo
uh outside and uh he went up to it and
he goes
uh wait did you guys already play what
happened prince rolled his window down
he goes
ask your boy and then they just peeled
off and then
i i never saw him again
i love that you're kind of in a
ping-pong basement like you're calling a
dog
just going prince
[Laughter]
i didn't know i didn't know if he was
hiding or what it was bizarre bizarre
when we heard about richard we were
promised it was going to be like this
you know really raunchy sexy
and i was watching it where is the sex
but my god once you
pull the rip cord it's it's non-stop
there's a bit i mean even you must have
been kind of
you know at the table reed you must have
been going up i haven't
spoken for pages
well i got my mouth full half a time
which i was consistent because i think
that's important to see on tv as well
because
that is uncommon that you see that kind
of power dynamic in rauchi scenes
and that's part of the way that we did
want to modernize the show so the duke
does have his mouth full and he's proud
of it
um but yes there was there was a fair
bit um to be done
on the show because you're really going
for it but you're going for it in
kind of beautiful locations i mean
like and occasionally very uncomfortable
locations well yeah those library steps
didn't look easy
um yeah the chiropractor but did you
have didn't you have room monitors in
the stately homes well this is a problem
because the set as usual is more
valuable than any of the actors so if
you're in like you know a 200 year old
bed or a 400 year old four poster
um it has to have a reminder like you
know when people kind of bring very
expensive jewelry around they have to
have
a bodyguard there's a bodyguard for the
room and so all times you know you've
got this
minimal set everyone gets very quiet
very respectful and you kind of you
de-robe
and you hit the bed and then there's
also just like fran in the corner who's
just standing there just kind of
deciding whether or not to look she's
like i have to look i'm not allowed to
look i have to look
could you please go easy on the bed it's
very very hard it's not
quite so enthusiastic oh do go on
that's the inner monologue that i
imagine is going on in the corner of the
room
i'll stop them in a minute and
presumably you had to have the awkward
kind of family conversation before yeah
a little bit
um i mean we've got a family whatsapp
group so there's a couple of you know
flash and red light emojis and the
peach emoji um certain people have
threatened to rate my peach
um but we missed a couple of family
lenders and so
people enjoy the fact that like a couple
of cousins missed the memo um and so
they're watching the show and i got a
very stern message
in my my instagram dms enough just going
there really needs to be a cousin
warming i had to make so many tactical
cups of tea
and i left the room and made my tactical
cup of tea and came back and you were
still going
so you had to start doing pots of tea
you know you had to kind of kind of keep
building up the three-course meal a
tasting menu
but it's a proper western i mean we see
tom hanks guntoten which we rarely see
well i don't have i don't wear one i am
given one
later on so it's not like you know i'm
not doing the root and tooting kind of
but i i i i ride a horse
and um i drive a wagon and i've
discovered so i'm not a i'm not a writer
per se but i did learn
i i had a fabulous got to know a
fabulous horp named wimpy who was my
horse wimpy was my heart
and um i don't know if anybody here is
has ridden a lot or
made a western emily has a couple of
westerns under her belt as i recall
emily my darling how are you
wonderful to see it's good to see you
you know i'm about to do a western like
next january i'm doing a six-part
western and we were just discussing how
allergic i am to horses and i do every
scene with a horse
you know i'm gonna be antihistamined up
to my eyeball
do you have to kiss the horse
isn't that what happens in western to
make out with your horse
you you develop an affection for those
beasts
every
which you sort of have to do because i
have a feeling that horses
honestly they would much rather live in
a world without human beings climbing on
top of them
and they know the moment you climb on
their back that you're terrible at
riding like i mean i've been learning
right now and
i'm in london now rehearsing for it and
i go riding
three times a week and every time they
give me a different horse to see
you know how you fare oh with one that's
more spoilery or one that's less of a
ferrari and i got on one the other day
called rusty
oh my god they almost took off with me
it was terrifying
i couldn't walk the next day rusty did
me in
rusty did her in rusty did man
oh wow is that the name of the film
let's spare thought for emma carr
because there are scenes
no there are scenes in the crown of
diana which one diana alone
in that big ballroom which is below oh
yeah doing her dancing i know that she
dances to elton john
and things well yes in the series i
danced elton john
oh okay but when we were filming it um i
remember ben the director saying
the day i before i do some ballet in
that episode as well very bad badly
and i had some lessons for that and he
said okay at the end of the day let's
choreograph something for
um you're like so because i meant to
like lose myself and just like go mad
and just dance in this space
and he said let's choreograph something
and i said is if it is okay if we don't
i'd just kind of like to feel it i could
turn them thinking oh no
and then
and then i was like and it's all right
if i pick the song
he was like yeah but obviously if it's
not from the period we can't use it and
i said that's fine
i'm just gonna pick a song and it's fine
just just for the day
and so i'm actually dancing to share do
you believe oh
yeah good trivia when you're watching at
home yeah
instead of soundtrack don't do that
but i remember we um but it must have
been was it
mortifying just having to go okay here
we go
i'm dancing alone to share i quite it
was actually quite freeing i quite liked
it
um i kind of just went for it but i
really went for it
and they just kind of like played the
music and these on these huge speakers
in this massive room
for like three minutes and i danced the
whole thing and i really threw myself
into it
and i was like going mad i remember they
called cart and i like
ended by like like going down to the
floor i think that's
made it into the show i remember the
silence and everyone was like
wow bit like tonight
and then ben just went emma that was wow
yeah that was great um
we're gonna have to do it again though
because you kept mouthing the lyrics
[Music]
he is like the sweetest individual in
the world
uh yes he played harry his name's harry
melling and
you i mean that was exciting for you to
do a scene with harry melling
it's moment yeah yeah
harry manning was her rihanna
tell us why tell us why he meant so much
to you well i learned to speak english
reading the harry potter books so as
lame as it sounds those characters
really were my first friends
um so still a big fan of the harry
potter franchise love the movies
oh my god look at him he played dudley
dursley i mean he's not an obvious one
but so many people don't come up to him
all the time
he's still part of the universe
and so what what language were you
speaking when you learned
to speak english through harry potter
spanish
oh okay and yeah so when did you come to
london
when i was six but i only learned
english
when i was eight because i was convinced
that if i didn't speak the language my
parents would have to take me home
and that failed miserably so i had to
learn
one of the things i found really moving
in the book was the way
you paid tribute to the achievements of
your children
was it sam who helped you with a bit of
online trolling
with the virtual world uh with the whole
online thing
so my daughter doing my instagram
they're doing my instagram posts
and my son is there to kind of
troubleshoot for me and very early on
and i was
it was my daughter explained to me what
fomo meant
because that was my whole life i was
fearful missing out because i couldn't
catch up with everybody
and uh so i i i she taught me that but
then i got i got in trouble
on twitter somebody who said something
nasty about
parkinson's and i usually let that stuff
just go by me it doesn't happen that
often when it does that
don't really care about it but i just i
wanted to answer this guy in some way
so my son said just do this do smh
and i said why don't he ask me he said
just just trust me do smh
so i answered the guy back smh and he
answered me back it's the funniest thing
i've ever read in my life
you're the king of the internet i
apologize for anything i said to you
blah blah blah blah and i said to my son
what the did you say
and he said shaking my head
[Laughter]
this film sees you reunited with uh
lokite stanfield from get out
so like when you're out and about people
must have loved it seeing the two of you
together again
yeah no yeah it was we went to a bowling
alley in cleveland because we shot in
cleveland
and then like people just coming up to
the cube doing
like flashing stuff and doing something
and i thought
man i thought it just happened to me i
felt less alone i was like oh man
oh man you know that's cool that's cool
but like i kind of sometimes just sit in
the corner with my hat level and just
pretend i don't exist
to myself though so like
i try to keep in the shadows and stuff
so is it you rachel's watching how many
you've watched it
a few times two or three times yeah yeah
we loved it so much and i'm sure this is
the point of the film but we literally
sat there going
get out get out of there
you must get out yeah when i have
conversations now i have to say
leave leave
and like that film did so well i mean it
took hundreds of millions of dollars
around the world
but is it true that you and why did this
happen that you you didn't go to the
premiere you weren't invited to the
premiere no they they didn't invite me
bro
they didn't no that can't be true on the
sundance world premiere yeah
i was in atlanta because i was shooting
panther i was shooting panther
and i was chilling and i was like i
cleared my schedule i was like y'all
really wanted it and then
just didn't they just didn't get the
invite man just didn't get it i didn't i
wasn't
i wasn't afraid so i was just in my bed
someone texts me it's gone really well
i'm like alright that's cool that's all
right
that's the industry graham no this is
the girl somebody up
has this come up since then like have
you asked them about it no no you don't
if i don't ask questions i just ah
i get it man that's cool like i i like
i'm very good
i i would send a stern left-handed note
but you mentioned you mentioned black
panther there and i it
black panther ii am i writing that is
now happening
that's what the streets are saying groom
that's what the streets are saying yeah
okay which will be very exciting but
also
kind of tinged with terrible sadness
because of course chadwick boseman's no
longer with us
yeah yeah man it's you know
i don't i don't even understand how like
it's gonna it's gonna we're gonna have
to honor him
you know honor him and honor give as
much to his
legacy as much as he gave to us because
he gave us everything
yeah you know stayed here to give us
everything and
like an incredible man an incredible
song you you play lots of instruments
but am i right you've learned
a new instrument in life i did um
a couple of things yeah i learned a
couple of instruments i i sort of really
got to grips with the didgeridoo
and um i um are you serious do you want
to judge your dude i don't think we do
and um
uh i got a lot of complaints actually
from neighbours um
people thought there was a swarm of bees
uh but
um i i actually also taught i've been
teaching myself this
instrument here which is um uh it's
it's something i've i've wanted to play
for a long time i play it occasionally
you know um but it's it's a mandola
and it's like a mandolin but it's a
deeper sound it makes a lovely sort of
like uh
a deeper sound i'll give you a little oh
yeah i'll give you a demo oh yeah
um i've written actually i've been
practicing with an irish real so i don't
know
if you uh this brings back any memories
i'll chat i'll start
our feet
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
oh something like that oh my dad would
have loved you you'd have come right
through the door
you